I've been trying to think of a decent
blind leading the blind joke for this
opener for the last five minutes and I'm
just gonna give up
[Applause]
[Music]
Daredevils back season three I don't
think I've actually talked formally
about this show on this channel before I
didn't get through the first two seasons
in a timely enough manner that it felt
worth doing reviews at the time I've
referenced them since and so for the
record I enjoyed the first season quite
a bit and the second season was half of
a good season and then completely fell
apart once the hand and Elektra took
over the plot so with that having been
established how was season three better
than season two certainly on the whole
and whereas as I said season two
completely fell apart however it does
suffer a little bit from being very
clearly an attempt to capture season one
again like really really down to a lot
of details so we've got all of the build
up to you know between kingpin and and
daredevil and Matt you've got the way
that kingpin threatens the people that
matter to math you've got trying to go
after kingpin legitimately and whether
or not that can even work
you've got your biggest and most
impressive fight scene in episode 4 you
have got this build up to this final
confrontation that is fine but somehow
feels oddly anticlimactic and a little
rushed despite having been built up all
that time too
so it does feel out a lot of ways like
they went okay what do people like about
season 1 do it again now that said it's
not a be for beat you know they they
completely redid the structure of season
1 all over again it's not that redundant
but I do think that they were chasing
that high that the first one had and I
mean that's never gonna work because it
it can't be the first time again it just
can't so even if you recreate it
perfectly it's not gonna be as strong
it's not gonna be as power
because it lacks that first impression
so what is the actual plot this time
around so obviously Wilson Fisk aka the
kingpin he finally starts getting called
that this season he has been in jail
since the end of season one so that
means that he is starting to make his
move and this begins with him cutting a
deal with the FBI basically saying look
all these criminal organizations that I
did business with and know the workings
of I'll tell you about them I'll name
names I'll give you the information that
you need to put these guys away and as
bad guys Wilson Fisk is that's kind of
an offer that the FBI is not about to
refuse now Matthew aka daredevil he has
been kind of well laying low is putting
it mildly since the events of the
defenders when basically a building fell
on him he has been in the care of the
church Whitney the one run by the priest
who knows who he is he and he's under
the care of sister Maggie who actually
helped raise him when he was there you
know as one of the orphans she was one
of the main people who tried to keep him
on the straight and narrow see how well
that kind of worked out all the while
you've also got foggy you have got Karen
sort of doing their own thing there is
an FBI agent who named Ray who is sort
of he's not really heading the whole
fist thing but he elbows himself in as
the point man for for things because
basically he's the guy who happens to be
from the FBI who happens to go to the
prison on the day that Fisk
decides to start talking so he's a guy
who's been you know seeing some personal
troubles and he's seeing this as a big
chance for advancement you've also got a
handful of other FBI characters that are
there
you've got cams boss because remember
she's working for a newspaper now you
know in fog he's working at at another
firm so he's dealing with more
high-powered clientele these days and
then there is the character of Ben
Poindexter who is wealthy
bullseye and he's I I would say that's
kind of a spoiler but it's kind of not
it's like it's been pretty clear in the
in the marketing kind of where some of
this we going and actually the early
trailers showed stuff from way later
episodes in the season I'm kind of
annoyed by that not like huge plot point
stuff but just you know you know me I
don't mean to pick these things apart
but if I see a scene and I'm it's gonna
get locked away in my head until I see
that scene again from the trailer and
then my brain goes oh yeah that was
really late I wish I hadn't already
known that but I'll talk about him in a
bit more detail in a little bit so
that's our layout kingpin starts to work
on Dex you know the the bull's eye
character and to get him over to his
side he gets a way to manipulate ray he
basically he plays the FBI like a fiddle
to his tune until while technically
still under a form of rest he is in fact
in a penthouse in a hotel that he owns
with all his stuff so yeah he has we
working the system to do exactly what he
wants it to do which pushes Matt towards
potentially more desperate means as he
he sees the system the law failed all
around Fisk so that's that's basically
our setup and like I said it's pretty
good it's it's probably the most solid
overall season in terms of not only
state and not only starting strong but
staying pretty close to that strength
level throughout the entirety of it
there's no massive fall down episodes it
doesn't take a nosedive halfway through
like a surprising number of the Netflix
Marvel TV shows have so all of that is
good and it's a pretty welcome relief
there's also a lot better through line
and thematic work going on this season
especially compared to season two
possibly even compared to season 1 and
what I mean by that is there was time
spent with characters that I'm and the
length of times
with them sometimes would have bothered
me except they were able to join
together sort of the journeys that
various characters were going through in
some cases there was one character that
I actually think we legitimately spend
more time with than we needed but I'll
come back to that and actually there's a
couple but anyway I'll come back to that
but what I mean is like sort of the main
thrust of the story was Matt Fisk and
Dex and their stories don't really
converge and come to a head in any like
meaningful physical sense for a while
but they do sort of weave in and out
similar thematic and narrative devices
in telling their stories because
basically all three of them are dealing
with this struggle between the world as
they perceive it or wish to perceive it
or which they weren't perceiving it and
the way it actually is and that's sort
of and I don't mean like literal
delusions although some of the
characters at some points is like how
crazy are you but there is that kind of
conflict going on with all three of them
so with those three characters
especially I didn't mind spending some
isolated time I even with Dex who was
new and that might have bugged me
especially considering that I've been
waiting for kingpin to come back and I
don't think you could actually give me
too much kingpin I'm not sure that's
possible but it worked pretty well and
it all balanced out pretty nicely as I
said that the best fight scene is in
episode 4 like Bar None there's this
prison fight that holy crap it's really
good and there's a fair number of good
action scenes
unfortunately there's an almost equal
number that are severely under lit I
know is this still happening how is this
still such a consistent problem with
these shows that fight scenes that look
like from what little I can make out are
probably really cool but I can't see
them and yes I understand it's two hits
to Matt's advantage as daredevil
to make the room really dark because he
it doesn't affect his ability to
perceive what's around him but it
affects the vision of the people he's
fighting I get
tactically but it's frustrating for me
to try and watch that when it's that
dark that's that's a case where
narrative justification doesn't fix the
problem so that was frustrating but like
that when the fight scenes are good they
are really good and they're
appropriately intense they're brutal but
they're I don't think this is as strong
as season one even sort of setting aside
the issue that I mentioned before of
it's kind of it's trying really hard to
recapture that same thing because it
there's there's some storytelling
sloppiness going on here especially
early on there's a lot of stuff that
moves forward on sheer coincidence so
like just a couple of examples is are
things like Matt after having gone
through basically just trying to recover
and like he's so he's so busted up from
what he went through at the end of
defenders he can't he can't even like
really perceive what's going around him
properly his hearing isn't working quite
right so his sort of echolocation thing
that he does that's not exactly
registering the way that it's supposed
to but it come he kind of gets it back
at least well enough that he goes out
and then by sheer coincidence the first
person that he helps save ends up being
someone who's kind of famous which means
Karen covers it for her newspaper which
means she gets the first hint that Matt
might still be alive
and coincidentally this guy also
connects to some fiste like this that's
a lot of stack piling of coincidences or
there's a point later on where foggy
gets this idea of a way to move forward
to try and you know take down Fisk
through the actual normal legal means
and he gets his big inspiration by a
court document that literally just
happens to spill out of his living
girlfriend's purse because she's a
lawyer too and he just happens to pick
it up and read it and go huh like that
come on and and like a couple of these
wouldn't matter me so much but it
happens a bit
and unfortunately I think the show
actually knows that because they they
try and they try and account for some of
the things that had been reading as
coincidences prior in the latter half of
the show but the kind of overstep and it
becomes one of those things where okay
so now you're telling me it's not a
coincidence but the level of things that
had to have happened for that to be
purposeful on anybody's part I'm not
sure I can buy that I think a
coincidence might have been better so
there's a little bit of that going on as
well I can't get into specifics of that
without getting into spoilers but I'll
get to that a little later actually I
think I might start going to spoilers
overall in general because I want to
talk about some of the specific
character and story beats and some of
the stuff that yeah I would count a
little bit more as spoilers at least if
you know you didn't watch a ton of
trailers because again fair amount of
this guy got wrecked in that but overall
it's good it's solid it also feels very
finished oh like I'm I mentioned this
before even seeing this season that the
story that it looked like they were
building towards in this season to me
feels like a good story to end with and
the end of this season does really feel
like a pretty significant wrap-up it's
not like there's zero story threads that
they could pick up later but it's
certainly not like the end of Luke Cage
season two or the end of iron fist
season two where like and here's what
the plot of the next season will be it's
just like a couple of things that could
factor in but probably couldn't carry an
entire season of television on their own
that are left dangling for the most
where it feels really wrapped up it
feels like a conclusion and I'm I would
not be shocked if in a month
Netflix cancels this not because it's
bad but it does seem like without
flat-out owning up to it Netflix is sort
of clearing the Marvel stuff off their
board so just given the nature of where
the story ends I think it's a perfectly
acceptable endpoint oh there's one other
thing that I'll mention in terms of sort
of the balance not quite being right
this season gets a bit more into well
not a bit more cuz there was some of
this in season two but it deals with
sort of the schlocky or more outlandish
comic book II elements of daredevil in
his world and kingpin in the way kingpin
operates and that's fine and all but the
problem is kingpin having been
established in the first season which
was the mean the first season of
daredevil was probably the most grounded
of these Marvel shows at all
I mean maybe Luke Cage season 1 but you
know it's not it's it's feeling real
ground level it's feeling really gritty
but by bringing back the villain who was
established in that season they try and
bring back that feel as well and there's
a little bit of a disjointedness there
because when you when you are presenting
things as outlandish as some of the
stuff that goes on here I don't mean
like superpowers outlandish I mean like
that's not how the legal system works
outlandish it's a little bit harder to
be to sort of brush aside those sorts of
nitpicks when the show is really trying
to ground itself in the more gritty
grounded versions of things
III think something like Dex is a good
example of that because bullseye is a
very comic book II character in the guy
I mean he just is he he is the sort of
character you don't really get outside
of comic books or really ridiculous
kinds of entertainment but they're doing
the more grounded gritty version of him
at the same time that they're taking a
lot of liberties with the idea of being
grounded in other areas and there's a
little bit of a disconnect there again
it doesn't send it totally off the rails
but I think it does sort of show how the
show is sort of fighting its own
evolution to a certain degree which i
think might have heard it a little bit
okay I'm gonna start getting into
spoilers and getting into more specific
stuff about what does go on so if you
haven't finished air devil season 3 yet
and you care you don't want to hear this
stuff this is the point to you know stop
watching me but it's solid I would say
check it out especially if you enjoyed
season 1 so getting into spoilers the
the specific background that they gave
Dex this sort of feeds into what I just
said is probably a little more grounded
and it should be I mean that basic while
giving him and never positively
identifying the never misses and can
turn any you know even vaguely sharp
item into a deadly projectile thing they
also tried to give him basically
Dexter's backstory like from the the
Showtime show Dexter Dexter exit
it's that coincidental because I don't
think bull's-eyes name is is Ben
Poindexter in the comics I don't think
they've actually ever said confirm what
his real name is anyways so like they
really do a lot to ground him in terms
in sort of explain his mental state to
explain why Fisk is able to manipulate
him and for the most part that works but
did that does feed into what I mentioned
before about them overstepping the
coincidence factor which is we find out
later that Fisk has basically been
moving the puzzle pieces to get Dex in a
position where he was gonna be able to
manipulate him and to get Rey in a
position where he was gonna be able to
manipulate him for a significant amount
of time before the season even starts
and that's too much it's not that I
doubt that the kingpin has that level of
influence that he can pull this off but
like that's just getting into
clairvoyant levels of knowing exactly
how things are gonna play out and part
of the thing with Fisk is his
relationships with people are awkward
enough that I don't think I I would
trust his judgment enough on how people
will respond to situations you know you
in a human emotional reaction kind of
way to be able to plan back many steps
ahead and have it actually all line up
and fall into place I think I think
that's pushing it too much I'm like I
said it it fixes the coincidence factor
on some of these things but replaces it
with in my mind a bigger problem where
the only way this works is if your
villain is just has pre cognizant and
that yeah so that that kind of annoyed
me a little bit I I really I was very
happy when Vanessa came back I wish she
had come back sooner in the show than
she did cuz I like Vanessa a lot
and I love her relationship with fists
the reason I didn't talk about this
before she comes she actually word she's
talked about almost the entire season
but she actually returns to the show so
late I just felt like I didn't even want
to touch stuff that late talking non
spoilers but now that I'm here I they
spent so much time building up her
return I was really nervous that they
were gonna somehow let me down or botch
her return because I'm like I feel like
there's been so much build-up please
don't let it just be a misfire and it
wasn't it wasn't I
love Vanessa and her dynamic with Wilson
Fisk so much because basically when you
get these sorts of situations you get
one of two things you either get sort of
the Godfather model in terms of like the
relationship between Al Pacino's
character and Diane Keaton's character
which is the spouse or you know
significant other who is being kept in
the dark
doesn't want any part of it which is
that you know the the organized-crime
person will get out of it or you get the
Lady Macbeth thing which is that day
that she is the secret power behind
thing pushing him and she's really the
one in control of everything and Vanessa
isn't quite either of those she is she
is a little closer to Lady Macbeth but
she wants to be Wilson's partner she
does push him but she pushes him towards
what she believes he is supposed to be
she's not manipulating him for her own
benefit and I love that dynamic and even
his first instinct is to protect her
from this and she gets annoyed with him
by that she kind of pulls back from him
she resents him a little bit that he
tries to hide his world from her when
she says flat-out
who you are and the world that you exist
in is why I love you it's why I want to
be with you don't shut me out of this
it's really it's a fascinating dynamic
and I love it so much honestly with the
exception of how extensive his plan was
would have to be by the time that you
get a full picture of it I other than
that I really have no complaints about
kingpin or his use in this I think he's
terrific I have my little niggles about
Dex daredevil and you know Matt
fine I think he's unfortunately kind of
the least interesting character of the
primary characters in this show but he's
he's putting in the work he's doing good
solid work in terms of especially in
terms of showing the struggle that's
going on with him right now I really
like sister Maggie now the revelation
that she was his mother didn't surprise
me I knew that from the comics but I
think the dropping of that I'm not sure
was completely played but as far as the
way that it altered character dynamics
or informed you about the character
dynamics that works that tracked and
that played out well enough we got that
extended flashback episode on Karen and
I'm not entirely sure why not that it
was bad but I don't know what that
information about her added to this
season really like when Fisk got a
flashback episode in season one it told
us a lot about him
this thing with Karen I mean basically
as soon as the flashback starts you can
track pretty much exactly where this is
going and then it goes pretty much
exactly there so and that's just based
off like the little bit she said and the
little hints we've gotten about her past
in her relationship with her father and
all that so I don't know why that's
there except to make the show 13
episodes and that's sort of the one of
the thing it's it's not padded
necessarily but it is stretched I'm not
sure there's except for the Karen
flashback and even that like that might
have worked as like little snippets like
five minutes highlights as opposed to
most of an episode so I don't it's not
padded but it's stretched and by that I
mean there isn't a bunch of stuff in
there that flat-out doesn't need to be
there but the stuff that is there is
stretched for more time than it needs so
like with Ray there is a surprising
number of episodes basically dedicated
to the his trying to find out what Fisk
is up to except we already know like
he's trying to find the evidence that
Fisk is manipulating
FBI but we know he's manipulating the
FBI we've known that forever and that's
not me saying the character is stupid
and that he should know that as well I'm
saying the audience is too far ahead of
the character we can't get invested in
the tension of will this character learn
something we as the audience already
know we're just kind of waiting for him
to catch up and again you can get away
with that for an episode maybe two but
they string they stretch that out for a
bit
and it's things like that that make it a
little bit weaker I think if this season
had I sort of dialed back on how
extensive Fisk's planning needed to be
was about three episodes shorter and
just cannot cut anything but just
condensed some of the stuff that it had
it could have been the best season of
daredevil as it stands it's the second
best buying season one I mean there's
only three so you know middle plays but
it's still pretty good despite you know
yeah sometimes I worry that I come
across as more negative than I actually
am but it's because you know when you
talk about why something works it
especially in a medium like film or
television is just kind of what they did
this thing and it works and unless they
did it in a really unusual way you don't
get as many minutes talking about that
as you do sort of breaking down the
reasons why something else didn't work
and then you end up with a
disproportionate amount of time talking
about stuff you didn't like even though
overall you enjoyed the thing that's
sort of the weirdness of this thing that
I do but in any case daredevil season 3
what did you think about it I'm assuming
you've seen it if you have watched all
the way through including the spoilers
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff you
can do down there too because there's
buns and there's links including a link
to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way it would be
amazing I think I hit 100 patrons which
is nuts
but awesome so but you know what if you
don't want to support me that way either
don't worry about it there's other links
there for you to check out too but in
any case don't sweat it because at the
end of the of the day you folks you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]